maybe you saw this report yesterday that
President Trump has apparently
repeatedly inquired about the
possibility of buying Greenland you know
that big that big hunk ice up north and
now I think personally this is exactly
the kind of weird but actually pretty
good idea that I hoped Trump would have
a lot more often I was hoping for
Trump to in my best case scenario Trump
would in his presidency have a whole
bunch of ideas that make you go well
maybe like that kind of reaction is what
I was hoping we would get and there
hasn't been enough of that in my opinion
there's been you know this space force
was one of those the first time you
heard it you're like really hey well
actually pretty good so we want I mean
if you're gonna hire someone like if
you're gonna elect someone like Trump to
be president then then I think buying
Greenland is exactly the sort of thing
the sort of idea that we would hope he
would bring to the table and it could be
great I mean Greenland has natural
resources they've got like polar bears
Hank or penguins one of the two at least
they have moose I don't know actually I
don't know what Greenland has I honestly
have no idea but just like everybody
else I have no clue but it would at
least be fun to brag about at the UN
meetings we could you know we could say
to the other UN ambassadors you know oh
hey we just finished that Greenland deal
no big deal we just you know we just
doubled the size of our overall landmass
no big deal whatever what are you up to
what are you doing so we could at least
do that but then comes outrageous news
just as we're all beginning to really
like the idea of owning Greenland the
the and and enslaving its inhabitants I
mean that was really that wasn't or sort
of my add-on I thought maybe we could do
that as well but we don't have to do
that just an idea just just an idea then
the Greenland government which consists
of you know three guys in an igloo they
emerge from their igloo and they issued
a statement they said Greenland is not
for sale
that's what they said well okay then I
guess we're gonna have to do this the
hard way you know we don't have john
bolton in the white house for no reason
if you get my drift okay you could do it
the easy way or you could do it the hard
way
and it looks like Greatland wants to do
it the hard way I think it may be time
if you know what I mean here it may be
time to spread some democracy and
freedom in Greenland in hint wink wink
honestly you could send one SEAL team in
not actual well maybe actual seals but
or Navy SEALs you could send one team in
and they could conquer the whole country
by by by dinnertime maybe there be two
casualties one guy slips on the ice
another guy gets trampled by a caribou
but other than that I think it'd be fine
Greenland just has to decide how it
wants to play this the balls in your
court Greenland your court which is
about to be our Court one way or another
all right so we'll keep an eye on that
but it's exciting stuff exciting stuff
so I want to discuss and look I know
that I say this all the time but I want
to begin today by talking about what is
potentially the most embarrassing and
possibly the stupidest boycott ever ever
and it happened yesterday and I know
that's saying a lot but I really think I
don't I don't think I'm exaggerating
this time no hyperbole we'll talk about
that in just a moment but first a word
from our friends at dynatrap you know
it's summertime and it to have your home
invaded by pests by flies and bugs
everything that can really ruin the vibe
I can really I can harsher your buzz as
the kids would say I guess there's a
little bit of a pun there too with the
bugs I didn't even do that on purpose I
just ruined it though by pointing it out
and dwelling on it like I am right now
and besides who knows where those flies
were last you know they carry germs they
carry diseases and so when they're
landing on your food they're in your
kitchen you got to think about that
that's why we'd like to thank our
sponsors over at dynatrap dynatrap is
the leading manufacturer of outdoor
mosquito and insect traps and now
they've come up with a solution they're
bringing all that know-how inside and
dealing with the problem where I think
it really matters and that's inside your
home and that's what the dynatrap fly
like the dynatrap fly light works day
and night to attract and trap flies
fruit flies mosquitoes other pesky
insects and you know it really works
we've been using this stuff for weeks
now and we haven't had any problem at
all with bugs in the house and that's
saying something
because we have three kids they're
constantly leaving the door open no
matter what we say they're always
leaving the door open and but we haven't
had a problem so you can get yours now
at dynatrap dot-com that's dy na t ra P
calm and to the promo code Walsh and
receive 15% off any of their products
I'm telling you you got to get this and
it's you know it's not like one of those
little sticky paper things it's just it
looks like a little subtle nightlight
that you plug into an outlet and you
forget about it and it takes care of the
problem for you dynatrap the safe silent
simple solution to household insect
control alright so yesterday the the
hashtags boycott CVS and CVS denies care
were both trending on social media and
if you went and checked those hashtags
you would have found lots of people
panicking that CVS was denying them
birth control CVS was attacking women's
access to birth control CVS was
attacking women's health CVS was
blocking access to birth control CBS was
preventing women from getting birth
control
CBS's anti women CBS is killing women
CVS is evil this is all the stuff you
would have seen on Twitter and the ACLU
obviously jumped in on the action
because there is no outrage to petty for
ACLU the ACLU there they're good if
there's a petty outrage anywhere they're
gonna be there on the scene near Al the
extremist pro-abortion group they were
on the dog pile as well well why what
what did CBS do wrong now you might
assume when you see this you would think
oh they must have what are they hike
their prices on birth control a little
bit or something like that
it's II know it's even it's even dumber
than that okay I told you this is the
dumbest boycott of all time that's not
an exaggeration get ready for this
the boycott began with a start-up
company called pill Club which is a pill
delivery service and if I could aside
notes for a moment to remark on the fact
that it's creepy yet appropriate that's
something called pill club exists in
modern America but in any case pill club
as I said is a start a company they
deliver pills
well pill club is in a dispute with CVS
because their contract with CBS came up
and CVS
wants to renew that contract with lower
reimbursement rates meaning pill club
would get less money from CVS for
delivering CVS's pills to customers and
that's it that that's the whole thing
that was the reason for a nationwide
boycott one pill delivery company will
be getting slightly less money for
delivering pills and this somehow
translates to women being prevented from
using birth control I mean it's just I I
don't think I've ever seen a boycott
that is this wholly unjustified and
pointless there been a lot of
unjustified and pointless ones but I've
never seen it this bad before so let's
let's follow this logic all the way
through
if CVS is charging pill club more or
rather they are paying pill club less
then that means pill club will either
have to charge its customers a few bucks
more or stop delivering CVS pills
entirely worst case scenario which means
that if you're a woman who has pill club
delivering you birth control pills
you're either going to have to pay a
little bit more or find a different
delivery company or god forbid leave
your house and go to the store yourself
to pick up the pills and somehow this
minor amount of energy being asked to
put in this tiny little bit of effort to
leave your hat you leave your house all
the time for things so now all you got
to do on your way home from all the
other things you're doing stop by CVS to
pick up your your birth control pills
that now is an attack on your very
health and well-being guys this birth
control thing is just so absurd at this
point we've now reached a point where a
woman is being attacked and being
prevented from using birth control if
the birth control is not transported
directly to her door for cheap if she
has to put in you know
if she has to pay a little bit more or
leave her house then she's being
persecuted meanwhile all the women who
complain that they can't here's the
thing if you are a woman in modern
America and you're claiming that you
absolutely cannot afford birth control I
don't believe you I just I'm sorry I
just don't believe you I think you can
afford it I really do I think you can I
certainly think you can leave your house
to get it if you really need it
or make other arrangements but I think
even aside from that you you is this
idea that I needs to be free or it's too
much but let's just stop it just stop we
live in that we live in in in a country
that runs on consumerism all of us we're
constantly buying things we don't need
we got I mean any doesn't really doesn't
matter what even if we're not talking
about birth control whatever it is
you're claiming you can't afford 99%
chance you can definitely actually
afford it it's just that you you've your
priorities you've prioritized other
things now if we're talking about a
Lamborghini or you know it's a
six-bedroom mansion then yes you most of
us can't afford that stuff but if we're
talking about just sort of every
everyday average items saying you can't
afford it you probably can the women who
complain that they can't afford birth
control and who claim that it's a basic
health necessity on top of it how many
of them have Netflix subscriptions how
many of them have Spotify subscriptions
how many of them have unlimited data
plans how many of them buy essentially a
whole new wardrobe every year I'd like
to see that Venn diagram because I'm
betting that Venn diagram is basically
just a circle with it would because all
of that is jumbled together of course
the whole idea as I said the whole idea
that anyone can't afford birth control
is is ludicrous anyone can afford it
because by the way we talk about birth
control that that's that is a category
that includes not just pills
also includes you know things that you
can buy at the gas station right so
again the idea that that there are
people who simply cannot afford anything
like that and so we have to get the
prices down or give it out for free
otherwise we can have all these unwanted
pregnant so-called unwanted pregnancies
and so on it's just ridiculous you know
I think that probably the majority of
people can afford it just fine on their
current income and it's not a problem
people are a little bit more strapped
for cash you know maybe you cut out a
few discretionary expenses if it's
important to you
a lot of this just comes down to
priority but we all have expenses that
we could cut out if we needed to but
this is even I I guess now we're at a
point where you need the birth control
for free it needs to be brought to your
house it needs to be brought in your
door walked up the steps placed into
your palm with a glass of water anything
aside from that and you're being
murdered essentially by by by the
Patriarchate come on it's just
completely ridiculous
alright by the way I love this tweet
from David Hogg moving on David Hogg
says it's harder to get cold pills that
an ar-15
something needs to change it's harder to
get cold pills like sudafed or something
than an ar-15 something needs to change
now I don't know where David Hogg lives
but apparently in in his neck of the
woods in his part of the country you can
go to the grocery store and buy a ar-15
for six bucks and you only have to show
the cashier your driver's license and
you're in and out in three minutes I
want to know what grocery store is this
what grocery store sells ar-15s for six
dollars and I know background check all
I got to do is just you know I go to the
the 16 year old cashier says can I see
your ID
look show them ID and I'm out of there
and where is that happening
the way the left talks about guns and
so-called assault rifles and so on it
just makes it really clear that they
they just have literally no idea what
they're talking about they've never
looked into this you have no clue what
is actually involved in buying a gun
what was that
famously I think Barack Obama claimed
famously was it that he said he said
that if I remember correctly said he
said it's easier to get a gun in a
library book or something
he said it's harder to get a book than a
gun wasn't it I got to look that up I'm
pretty sure it was a book this kind of
comparison where it's well it's harder
to get X than a gun liberals are doing
this all the time and the comparisons
just keep getting more and more
ridiculous harder to get a book than a
gun no to get an ar-15 let's start with
the fact that they're very expensive
which is which is a barrier for entry
for a lot of people a lot more expensive
now that's something that you really
might not be able to afford unlike birth
control pills or a contraception of any
kind they're expensive there's a
background check involved it's you can't
just walk into a place buy an ar-15 and
you're out in two minutes it's not how
it works if people like David hog would
take the time to do just a slightest
amount of research into what they're
talking about they would discover this
all right here's something else from
this is an interesting report from The
Daily wire interesting slash hilarious
it says the Journal of one New York
University's Women's and Gender Studies
Program so you know it's gonna be good
this is a journal from a New York
University's Women's and Gender Studies
program you know whatever is gonna
happen whatever whatever is whatever
comes next you know it's good it's
published a paper that insists that
milking cows is comparable to sexual
abuse emotional trauma related to
pregnancy and non-consensual hormone
treatments oh my gosh the paper oh well
okay the and this is not a joke
apparently this is real
the paper is titled readying the rape
rack feminism and the exploitation of
non-human reproductive systems was
included in dissenting voices published
and edited by the Women's and Gender
Studies program at the college at
brockport State University of New York
Ryan notes that the author and intern
for Brockport's Women's Studies
department
Ryan is Celine Ryan is writing for
campus reform she says an intern for
Brockport's women Studies department has
success she must discuss the
under-researched
feminist aspects of animal agriculture
adding the same way women's health has
been at stake for years a dairy cows
reproductive system has been poked and
prodded the author writes throughout our
lives we were offered an idealized image
of dairy cows where these animals graze
on beautiful pastures have room to sow
and play and our company did spacious
areas which to sleep we are presented
with images of a life well-lived but
when it comes to the deaths of those
same animals the picture per the
picture-perfect story comes to a grim
reality dairy cows are forcibly
impregnated or raped on mobile okay
anyway it goes on from there so this is
this is a this is a feminist issue with
you feminists now comparing themselves
to cows apparently it's actually
interesting because over the last few
days we've been during the email portion
of the show we've been talking about
factory farming because I had say a
vegetarian email me a few days ago and
and and tried to say that you know I
shouldn't be so dismissive of the
vegetarian argument because even if I
don't agree with it it's not irrational
and I said when it comes to criticisms
of factory farming that's certainly not
an irrational criticism I think there's
something to be said about that
so if you want to make a criticism of
factory farming there are so many
avenues you could explore there's so
many arguments you can make yet somehow
this person managed to make the craziest
and most delusional argument possible
that's good stuff all right what else
well there's this story about Talib and
Omar being banned from Israel I was
gonna do a whole thing on this but I
realized I don't care that much
Israel can do what it wants makes no
difference to me
either way honestly and that's my
analysis I guess I was gonna go into a
whole thing but I think you've heard
enough people probably talk about it
frankly I find the subject boring so
we'll move on and in fact we'll get
right to emails Matt Walsh Oh at
gmail.com
Matt well show at gmail.com they're a
bunch of good email so I want to give
time on a Friday for the emails this is
from Jake says great overlord of this
multiverse and other multiverses
yesterday you gave the example of the 16
year old boy dating a 49 year old man
that was highlighted on pink news you
talked about how aside from the gay
aspect of this story it's inherently
evil for a young person to date or marry
an old person so as a Christian I asked
myself is it actually wrong to have such
a large age gap with someone you're
dating or married to if neither person
is underage let's say for the sake of
argument that there's some minimum age
involved like 18 or 21 biblically
speaking is there any reason why an 18
year old morally shouldn't date or marry
a 50 year old assuming they are opposite
genders what about 18 and 35 where's the
line I agree it's weird and goes against
our cultural norms for now but what is
the biblical argument for being so evil
if it's consensual and neither person is
underage I've heard before though not
proven fact that Jesus's mother Mary was
probably in her earlier mid-teens as his
father Joseph was probably in his
mid-30s when they got married and had
Jesus if that's true we'd have let's say
a fifteen-year-old marrying a 35 year
old is this a reasonable age gap
technically Mary would have been
underage by our standards just curious
what your thoughts are on this and where
you draw the line always appreciate your
insight well I don't think I said it's
inherently evil for a young person to
marry an old person hey I certainly
don't think that but when you talk about
age gaps and what we were discussing
yesterday just to be clear this was a
story in pink news which is a gay news
site they were celebrating the story the
the quote-unquote relationship between a
50 there was like a 55 year old man and
a 22 year old guy except that they had
been quote-unquote dating for six years
which means they started quote-unquote
dating when he was 49 and the kid
sixteen that is clearly not not just
inappropriate but that's read sexual
abuse and then you add on top of it it's
bad enough given the ages but you add on
top of that the fact that this guy even
at 22 it looked like it was about ten so
you can imagine what he looked like wait
sixteen what does that tell you about
the the you know the sexual proclivities
of this older guy so that clearly is
wrong however I don't think I ever said
that it's inherently wrong for there to
be some sort of age gap between between
two people who are in a relationship
it's just that there's a difference
right there's a there's a difference
between say someone who's 35 being
married to someone who's 50 there's a
difference between that but and even
something like 35 and 20 now at 35 to be
in a relationship with a 20 year old
that's legal nobody could say it's
illegal but I do think that oftentimes
it can be well just that the difference
in in maturity you know I guess that's
what it comes down to the maturity gap
between a 55 and a 35 year old is very
small it may be non-existent because you
get to a certain point where you've
grown you're an adult now you've been an
adult for a long time you know you've
and you've just experienced life and so
the difference between you and and
that's why it's 35 you could get along
with someone who's 50 and as a peer
really but some of these age gaps are
talking about here 18 and 35 you
mentioned well the maturity gap between
an 18 year old and a 35 year old is
going to be enormous I mean I'm I'm 33
right now and I think back to myself and
I was 18 basically a whole other person
the difference between met me now at 33
and when I was 18 is so vast that it's
it feels like it wasn't even me I was I
might as well at 18 I might as well have
been you know five years old maturity
wise adding it
so that's why it can be in some case now
maybe there are exceptions you know that
you could have a 20 year old who's just
really mature and has their act together
it's a I'm not saying there aren't
possibly exceptions I just think that
you know for someone who is
significantly more mature and
experienced to be in a romantic
relationship with someone who is
significantly less experience than
mature then I think that's where it can
be strange even if it's perfectly legal
all right this is from Ben says dear
future overlord what is the funniest
verse in the Bible I believe it is
proverbs 27 14 every time I read read it
I laugh however if I'm wrong I will
submit to your authority I will proclaim
the correction has the actual funniest
first in the Bible you know I think that
there's a lot of great things to be said
for the Bible of course it is the Word
of God at the end of the day but I ate
you know I would like it if there's a
little bit more comic relief there's not
a lot of that if I had to point to the
funniest verse in the Bible for me and
you know I hope I'm not venturing the
blast from here I the the verse of Jesus
cursing the fig tree I've always found
kind of funny but I understand that it's
symbolic significance of it and
everything but just on a human level it
just seems like the kind of thing that I
might do if I was God where you want it
you know you you want to take a fig from
the tree and it doesn't have figs and so
you get ticked off and you curse the
tree and in one of in one of the Gospels
that it tells you that the Apostles are
standing there and they're saying Jesus
is I mean the things not in the things
not in season that's why they're trying
to explain they don't understand so I
think from what makes that funny is is
from the Apostles perspective they don't
understand the symbolic significance of
the cursing the fig tree so from their
perspective Jesus was just ticked off
and in a bad mood so he cursed the fig
tree just for the sake of it which is
you know I think it's coming all right
this is from Ken says I know this may
sound harsh but after hearing your
discussion about Marty's deleted tweet I
got to thinking that's Marty Sampson who
deleted it was actually an Instagram
post not a tweet he's the lead singer of
a well-known Christian rock band who
posted something on Instagram saying
that he's doubting his faith and his own
the
of leaving his faith by that's what
we're talking about ken says all of his
complaints seem to be about how other
people weren't doing things for him
people weren't talking about fallen
pastors people weren't talking about
contradictions people were talking about
miracles he's a leader in his church if
not his global community it behooves him
to teach people to teach people these
things it seems he is in a unique
position to go and learn solid doctrinal
truths and then to convey those truths
in song just because it's deep doesn't
mean you can't sing about it for
hundreds of years writers of hymns have
dealt with deep theological and
complicated doctrinal issues and put it
to song instead of complaining about how
other people weren't dealing with deep
theological issues he should have been
discovering those and then singing about
them though he's 40 years old and I
don't think it's qualified as a
millennial I think he's been too
influenced by them this seems to be and
I hate to say this one of the aspects of
a younger generation trying to come to
grips with what is their job and what is
everyone else's job they said the same
thing about Gen X when I was in my 20s
and 30s that were useless we don't know
how to work we're lazy and we'd rather
just sit around all day instead of doing
something productive
and here's what all those baby boomers
and those great generation folks told me
get your butt up and go to work if he
doesn't like it that the leadership
which he is a member of isn't talking
about those things that he should take
it upon himself to step in and talk it's
not for him to sit there and complain
that the ball is just sitting there on
the five-yard line and no one running it
in pick it up and run with it
yeah I think I think you make a good
point here and I don't I don't deny it
and I said yesterday a lot of these
issues that he's struggling with
apparently are serious issues you know
he's dealing with the problem of evil
alleged contradictions in the Bible
apparent contradictions in the Bible
other things like that those are serious
issues very deep issues there's nothing
wrong with struggling with them I think
it'd be weird if you didn't struggle
with them I mean if you as a Christian
if you've never had a point in your life
where you really stopped and dwelled on
those problems and felt troubled by them
that I just think that shows that you're
not really taking your faith all that
seriously and you're not thinking
through things so there's nothing wrong
with that and as I said yesterday I
think there is a problem with pastors
not addressing these issues from the
pulpit there are exceptions in fact I
have an email from someone who's a
pastor who touches on this maybe I'll
get to add a minute so there are
exceptions but for the most part these
are issues that on the sort of popular
mainstream Christian level aren't
discussed and I think that is an issue
now as you point out he was a member of
the popular mainstream Christian scene
and a leader of it and so it should have
been one of the ones bringing this
conversation up and I agree and that's
why I think although the questions he
raises are reasonable questions and good
questions and we should try to address
them I'm not trying to absolve him of
all responsibility of course I don't do
that and at the end of the day whether
you're you know that the leader of a
Christian rock band or not matter who
you are even if these issues aren't
being addressed in church it does as you
said boovs us to go and pursue those
answers I just think we shouldn't have
to pursue them quite as much because
this is what churches should be doing so
one of the main things churches should
be doing in my view all right this is
from Thomas then we just read one oh if
we have two emails from two different
Thomas's this is from Thomas's hey Matt
I was a co on Rikers Island until I
retired about two years ago and it's not
uncommon for CEOs to sleep on the
midnight tour it seemed to me that some
CEOs took it for granted that it was a
given that they would sleep some housing
areas had spas inmates suicide
prevention aides as SP a is a is the
acronym there who were supposed to
supplement our tours of the area and let
us know of any problems with any inmates
I never really trusted s pas and I would
have preferred to have them locked in on
the midnight tour I was pretty vigilant
in making my tours with my trusty
rechargeable stream light hey you never
know also we were taught that an inmate
could hang themselves from low places as
well on Rikers like at MCC there was
tons of mandatory overtime a common
refrain from the captain would be you're
stuck another was put an H on your chest
and handle it and some jails on Rikers
cos would get stuck four out of four
days most CEOs on Rikers
worked a four and two day rotation four
days on two days off you also work also
many work the wheel which is a different
shift every week also I was thinking
could Epstein's broken bones have come
from him possibly thrusting his head
forward a bunch of times possibly to
overcome instinct for survival and
perhaps that might explain the shrieking
that supposedly occurred we'll never
know but it would make for a good movie
like the International which I watched
the other day but it was only available
in pay-per-view and I was feeling cheap
that day thanks for that added note at
the end you know your your perspective
and insight as a as a former prison
guard is valuable so that's interesting
and slightly concerning to know that
sleeping on the job among prison guards
is so common not sure I'm a huge fan of
that but the idea that he could have
broken his own neck by thrusting his
head forward it's possible it just seems
implausible to me it seems very
implausible the kind of force that would
be required to do that well you just you
don't hear about very often people
thrusting their head back and forth and
breaking their neck in the process again
possible I think implausible so no
matter what whatever the explanation is
whatever happened it's definitely it's
it's something somewhat incredible
happened we're only left for a guy
especially given the situation and given
the importance of this person importance
because of the information they have for
him to be able to break his own neck
that would be an incredible turn of
events the other possibilities which may
include for instance you know someone
getting to him paying off prison
officials or whatever would be if all
that would also be incredible and so now
it's just sort of which explanation is
more incredible and I guess it's left to
each individual to decide that this is
from the other Thomas is the pastor I
mentioned before
says hi Matt I never missed your show
and I appreciate you being upfront about
things the Apostle Paul called hard to
be understood as an independent baptist
pastor who frequently covers apologetics
the harmony of the Gospels and
seemingly confounding questions from the
pulpit I can tell you from experience
that only a very small percentage of
Christians actually retain or work to
retain such technical information I
think that's why many pastors avoid
these things from the pulpit because
they figure what's the point
however some such as myself still do
address these things in pulpit ministry
because even if the people don't often
retain it at least they know now that
there are explanations if they want them
this increases their faith even if they
don't allow their knowledge to be
increased so much they end up knowing
explanations exist they just can't
articulate them like you or me just
imagine if all Christians learn to
articulate difficult things about the
Christian faith perhaps we'd have
retained a little more respect over the
years the other reason I still address
difficult things in a pulpit is because
of trust in leadership these people well
we'll know that I'm going to tell them
the truth because some of these issues
we deal with don't have a slam-dunk
answer a leader willing to say we don't
fully know that proves this honesty I
like what Ravi Zacharias says God has
put enough into this world to make faith
in him and most reasonable thing but he
has left enough out to make it
impossible to live by sheer reason alone
faith and reason must always work
together in that plausible blend thanks
for all you do yeah Thoms I think that
that's that's probably one of the
reasons why pastors don't address don't
pastors aside from yourself and the
minority who do the reason why there
might be one of the reasons why most
pastors don't address these difficult
issues is because I guess as you say
they figure what's the point I think
though more common reason I think
probably are there a lot of pastors who
don't just don't think about these
things either and don't understand them
enough to talk about them don't study it
just don't take it seriously I think
that it's very clear to me that there
are a lot of church leaders in this
country whose who have an understanding
of the of the Bible that is it's very
paltry and pathetic and so all they can
really do is give you talking points and
cliches and surface-level because that's
all that that's as far as their own
understanding goes so I think that's
part of the problem and I think there's
also a cowardice among some pastors that
they don't want to get into these deeper
issues and problems they especially
don't want to as you said you know with
some of these things there isn't a
slam-dunk answer there isn't really an
answer at all you get into the question
you think about it you dissect it and at
the end of it you're left still with a
question and that's okay because we're
not going to understand everything in
the universe but I think there are some
pastors who are afraid of that and so
they don't want to talk about it but
either way I think all of these excuses
are bad because this is what what you do
as a pastor is exactly what pastors need
to be doing what's the point if you're
not addressing the questions that really
matter and that people are the kinds of
things that really trouble people at
least trouble the people who bother to
think about them if you're not
addressing that then what what why even
get up there and say anything what is
the point if you're going to avoid all
of the difficult questions related to
faith then I just think that you're in
the wrong profession entirely you might
as well go you go be a used car salesman
there's just no reason for you to be
doing this not you specifically but
pastors in general so I like what you're
doing I think you're being a little too
generous maybe to some of your pastor
friends who don't do the same thing I
think this is exactly what needs to be
done something like you know there's the
issues of the Bible but things like as
we talk about the problem of evil the
problem of suffering I'm not saying that
every time you get up there on the
pulpit you need to be dealing with that
question but this should be a question
that is returned too frequently because
this is one of the core problems one of
the one of the main issues that people
have all right but thanks for the email
thanks everybody for watching I'm on
vacation next week so I'll talk to you
in a couple weeks
Godspeed if you prefer facts over
feelings if you aren't offended by the
brutal truth if you can still laugh at
the nuttiness filling our national news
cycle well tune on into the ben shapiro
show or you'll get a whole lot of that
and much more we'll see you there